tensions are high in one of the world's
most strategic regions after attacks on
two tankers near the Persian Gulf the
United States claims Iran carried out
the suspected coordinated attack on the
Japanese and Norwegian own ships iran's
Foreign Minister denies it calling the
accusations part of a plot and the u.s.
points to this video released overnight
that American officials say set shows
Iran removing evidence from one of the
tankers this all happened in the Gulf of
Oman not far from the Strait of Hormuz a
hugely important waterway for global oil
shipments David Martin is at the
Pentagon David what is the u.s. saying
about the attack good morning a US
officials say the evidence Iran is
behind the attack on the two tankers is
compelling the question now is what does
the Trump administration plan to do
about it this assessment is based on
intelligence the weapons used the level
of expertise needed to execute the
operation one reason Secretary of State
Pompeo laid the blame squarely on Iran
is this video the US says it shows an
Iranian patrol boat coming alongside and
removing an unexploded mine from one of
the tankers hauls making off with the
evidence in other words the US says
other mines planted by Iran did explode
leaving one tanker so badly damaged it
was in danger of sinking and the other
in danger of drifting into Iranian
waters CBS News consultant retired
Admiral sandy Winnefeld explained how an
attack like this could be pulled off
this was actually a fairly high skilled
attack probably conducted by a small
boat coming alongside the ship attaching
a limpet mine or two or three to the
ship and then making its escape in time
to avoid the explosion but the owner of
one of the tanker says before the attack
the crew saw flying objects suggesting
mines were not the cause regardless of
how the attack occurred the bottom line
is the same the end of the day this will
create more instability in the Gulf
region it's not going to help things at
all and when there's less instability in
the Gulf region for Americans that means
potentially higher prices at the gas
pump and potential for conflict should
this escalate secretary Pompeo said the
US respond
- the attacks would focus on diplomatic
and economic measures Iran should meet
diplomacy with the slum mostly not with
terror bloodshed and extortion US
officials say no military strike against
Iran is imminent but winterfeld says he
doesn't think it would take much more
from Iran to trigger one Tony David if
the u.s. is correct and Iran is behind
these attacks what would the country
gain by striking tankers well right now
the u.s. is using economic sanctions to
try and cut off Iran's oil exports which
are its main source of revenue so right
now
Iran is fighting for its economic life
and by attacking tankers coming out of
the Persian Gulf it is sending a message
to other countries in the world
that it still has the power to put their
oil supplies at risk and I think their
hope is that if they can create enough
sense of uncertainty about their energy
supplies among other countries in the
world those countries will convince the
u.s. to ease off on its pressure
campaign against Iran alright David
Martin for us at the Pentagon David
thank you